look at my eyes real quick
are you gay no look at my eyes real
quick
are you gay no okay this is that was
hard
it doesn't work it doesn't work
all right this is gonna be a good one
we're watching six straight men
versus one secretly gay man oh you know
what to be good
six non-simps and one secret simp
that'd be good that one's for free you
belay just because i get to react to
your videos
for those who don't know this the point
of this show is
why did i explain it it's so obvious
it's in the title never mind
we brought together seven straight men
and they do explain it i'm straight
i all right all right let's see if we
can get it straight off the bat
get it straight haha i mean i would
guess this guy
because he's clearly the one that's
dressed as the most stylish he's doing
the high pants the tuck the roll up
sleeves
the very sort of the haircut
i would say yeah but that's obviously a
lie this is not
that's a decoy easy decoy understand
this guy's talking to my dude
uh they always go like the least gay
looking guy
like you wouldn't expect i was like this
guy or this guy we brought together
seven straight men
i put my money behind the street i am a
straight man i'm sure
no you're not he's not straight straight
man i'm straight
i am a straight man i'm sorry ah look at
that he's got a glimmer in his eyes like
i am a straight uh he looks gay too come
on i'm straight
i i'm a straight all right he's you're
clear i changed my mind ability
you're not straight you're gay evan's
gay yeah
i am a straight man i'm straight i am uh
he could be gay too actually
i didn't see corbin corbin you gay dude
you're all gay
i am i think it's corbin straight man
one
is a liar sorry should i just watch the
video and shut the [ __ ] up all right my
bad
i just i just want to see if i could get
a surprise by looking
if the liar survives it's my gaydar wins
the entire
correct or nine i don't know
my vote's on corbin right now raise your
hand if you have if you've had a
girlfriend
are you sexually attracted to men
no but uh i can appreciate a good man
okay
my man you're wearing a [ __ ] key as a
necklace
you use a gay ain't nothing wrong with
that by the way just so we're clear here
this is a welcoming channel whatever
your preference is
[Music]
whoever you want bro i don't care but
you wear a
key as a necklace my do you gay
you gay as hell no but uh i can
appreciate a good man
okay that makes sense i can appreciate a
good mane
that's like saying you know what's a
meal i don't like
no i don't like coriander and i refuse
to eat that
but i can appreciate a good coriander
that does not happen
what's a man that i like
it's definitely some i can think like
yeah they look good but hey
i don't have anyone in my head tom hardy
martial yelp come hardy yes
thank you
now that's amazing he's got hard in his
name come on
oh that guy from uh how to get away with
murder
oh he doesn't look that good in real
life though never mind
crush ruined all right sorry we're
looking at the gate
you have a wedding ring i do when did
you get married uh
eight years ago eight years ago they're
singling out on him
ah he got married why okay all right all
right what's your wife's name
stephanie wow do you guys believe that
right off the bat yeah you guys believe
stephanie
okay the fact that everyone thinks he's
gay makes me think i retract it corbin
you're not gay
i changed my mind uh kind of went after
me because
uh i had a wedding ring oh god no
because you're wearing a key
the key is it's the key to all of this
who here has kissed a dude or been
kissed by a dude i think it's by a dude
everyone
yeah [ __ ] yeah i kissed guy what
so why gay i kissed guy a little time
ain't nothing gay kissing men
two men ain't nothing gay about that is
manly nothing man near the two guys
can't argue with science
kiss at least you can't be a simp if
you're gay huh you ever thought of that
you [ __ ] homophobes kiss the dude yes
i think it's by a dude who here has
kissed a dude and liked it
we're not saying it's wrong we're saying
it's game my dude that's different
no there's nothing wrong carbon but it's
gay do you understand
uh yeah i've been kissed by a guy and
i'll never forget it because it was the
most traumatic experience of all time
and i don't understand how women does it
i felt the beard that i don't want to
feel and i'll never forget it
i don't even want to talk about it i
accidentally kissed my best friend on my
birthday one of my best friends
you don't accidentally kiss an accident
yeah it was really funny my girlfriend
sounds like you're lying jared we have
six straight men and one secretly gay
and then one secretly secretly gay
yeah so clear now wow
like okay so ah damn it who who knows
who won the super bowl
was that does that matter when i don't
watch it oh my my dude you're gay
does that matter oh he's so gay he
brought that up because he thought that
would be a good lie
right he brought that up so he could be
like oh yeah he had that ready in his
head before he went in
who can say who won the super bowl he
tried to go and attack there
but he failed completely because all the
guys are like what
that has nothing to do with your sexual
orientation corbin
what are you gay or something yeah wait
jason
oh yeah uh corbin's out i didn't think
he was the mole yeah
but when it came down to it i was like i
gotta play for strategy i gotta win
really
yeah corbin only person you asked the
question too
that's what happens in all of these
episodes is the only person they ask a
question to
is the one that gets voted out has
anyone here been mistaken for
a gay person i get mistaken for being
gay all the time which is why i don't
think like it's
you could tell by someone yeah exactly
tell through their story
i don't get mistaken for being gay what
does that say about me
i mean how could you identify a person
by their physical appearance whether
they're gay or not i don't think that's
possible and that's the conversation i
tried
it's definitely possible because you all
just proved it by eliminating corbin
i feel like for this to be effective we
have to put everyone kind of in the spot
and like and then everyone else just
analyzes them
ask me questions you mean the point of
the show my dude
wait wait look at my eyes real quick are
you gay no
look at my eyes real quick are you gay
[Laughter]
because they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing this is so hard
i asked andy and just because it can't
just be like oh
everyone gangs up on one person because
like then the gay person has
a chance like hide in the shadows or
hide in the noise you know
it was they keep going with a looking
strategy seriously
it was if they're gay they're gonna act
different they're very like
you know 1960s like mindset in that
which is funny and i was like
i don't think we're gonna get anything
out of this i know i don't think so
either cena penis
i've seen multiple penises how how did
you feel about them
what is this strategy i can't
what did you feel about them
has this guy ever met a gay person what
do you feel about the penis
when was your first girlfriend my first
one was probably like
in college yeah it was it wasn't very
long though so yeah my thing could be
about i'm like muslim so my thing is
like it's just dating is just usually
very
unconventional and it's like very like
limited so i mean
is that a thing in muslim culture i'm
i'm basically mainly on his uh posture
and gesturing
i feel like as far as like religion goes
i mean usually is another thing where
it's like
really pretty devout i would say yeah
okay
like i grew up like going to the mosque
and everything it's a very like don't
ask don't tell
it's something that needs to be
addressed there should be a lot of love
coming out just in general you know it
shouldn't be something
maybe we were a bit we jumped the gun a
bit on
colleen because nabil uh yeah it's gonna
be like i changed my mind it's not bl
people get ostracized for doing what
they do and being who they are how's
your relationship with your dad
how's your relationship with your dad
what the [ __ ] are you trying to ask him
out
play baseball with him sit why is that a
question it's a relationship
i'm not actually a jerk guys last person
open book
uh give it to me jonathan do you shave
your butt
what do you wax no i don't i don't you
know that he can just liar right what
the
what is this guy's question that's so
good
you sure you're right because that gay
no
oh i guess you're not gay then we don't
i don't okay unfortunately
sorry have you ever had a threesome i
have not i
like i don't i don't understand it like
i gotta focus on one person
and who usually who's that one person a
man or a female a girl yeah okay
[Laughter]
they are so bad they are so bad this is
the worst episode i've ever
seen this guy looks like a lost kid in
legoland
have you kissed a dude he said he didn't
i i have
what was okay what was the situation
don't you want to say no
i don't want to say no i want to be
honest i've kissed a guy because i was
like i could be bi
and then turns out i wasn't what would
that make you the mole
no way he went out he's definitely it's
not wesley raise your hand if you think
the mole is still in the square and you
would like to continue the game
you just gotta be safe the calling out
is so like bad i apologize but it's a
game it's a game you just say it i think
you're gay
right and so this is what i think
there's a lot of
dominating the conversation the body
language and trying to control
everything
i thought he was acting maybe too macho
okay maybe he is
over playing no i don't have a straight
role i don't think i'm going to look at
wesley
you know what really sucks about this
guys is we became friends and now i feel
like we're not
so like after this is over can we still
get beers yes all right
if you want to the one thing i'll say
i'm sure if you guys vote me off
all right let's do that then one eight
times what a guy or
gaydar being right in real life i don't
believe in that kind of a thing
oh sorry that's so hard i've been pretty
on
i would say my brother he's he's gay
and i didn't know until he came out and
i was like whoa what the i was like
shocked
okay and so yeah the like case
stereotypes doesn't really match up
but did it ever like cross your mind or
anything like did you ever even think
about it
no i didn't it's a lot because a lot of
the times like what you're not paying
attention to
right it's like it's easy to miss you
know what i mean
right i just i thought dude yeah
disqualifying
yourself he's very quiet
very quiet dude
it's him what's the
gayest thing about you all dude honestly
growing up me and my friends literally
just like poked out that's pretty smart
what the [ __ ] really hey dude no
dude what happened take two fingers or
something no let me explain
it's so gay it's so
and there's this thing called where it's
like horseplay or whatever
oh yeah behind one of your friends and
like ain't nothing gay about
penetrating your your boys huh i did
that come on
you're like finger up their butt that
ain't gay that's epic
and not saying gay is an epic but like
bro why'd you move over there
i'm just i'm just trying to they're
called right and so like basically
i'm not hating i thought it's funny but
i was with him in it like okay i hear
you i don't think you're it
is that considered gay because that's
gay happiness like people might be like
yo that dude's a little too happy i'm
like yeah i am
that's a good thing i think the gayest
thing that is
so this is the weirdest episode we've
gotten so far
i can't believe this is just a bunch of
dudes that
are brewing it out it's so funny
everyone's like oh my god are you gay
and i'm like does it matter but how
about how does that situation come
across are you like hey can i massage
you
it's all consent it's all consent no so
they're my friends if you do gay stuff
like
you're cool you're probably not gay wait
what
say say
say that one again cheap what do you
what was eight if you do gay stuff like
you're probably not gay
where did they find this guy uh it's
such a good episode
i love it i remember in school like so
everyone
all the boys were teasing each other oh
you're gay
oh you're gay oh you're gay ain't
nothing wrong with being gay
even if you're not gay you know what i'm
saying and i'll tell you what
all the people that always went oh
you're you're gay
they are hiding in they are doing it
they're projecting it
at least that's how looking back out of
my class
the people that went oh you're good
they're the gay ones
just like taste and music you know i'm
like a beyonce fan i've been listening
to like britney spears since like day
one like that's the kind of stuff like
i'm just really into like pop music and
uh that's that's my thing i guess
now that makes me think he's not gay
anymore i don't know
if i do ask you yeah no homosexuality on
like the
like the muslim community yeah that's
fine i feel like a lot of religious
organizations kind of take that
conservative approach where they're like
okay you know just uh
everybody's allowed in the religion the
thing that throws me off about his
argument and i don't know if i
understood it correctly
but i think he was mentioning like yeah
i'm not gay because i'm
i'm par i'm part muslim or something
like that and they're not very accepting
of gay people which i don't know if
that's even true or not but
that was his argument but that doesn't
make him not gay that just makes him
muslim if that right i i
i think he i think it's him you can't
really so if you were would you be
comfortable like coming out
would i be yeah probably not just i'm
being honest for myself and just because
i know how muslims are like i probably
wow if it's not wanting to be alive
that's crazy
wesley and evan whoa
i don't like this game anymore can i go
[Music]
home
evan sorry dude sorry brother i thought
wes was definitely
the guy that's right i don't think it's
i wanted to split the money with evan
but if everyone else is being greedy or
so i thought then i guess i got to be
greedy with everybody else
this is what i'm thinking all right
because saying i'm muslim is like the
ultimate trump card of saying like
yeah yeah i get that yeah that's right
anyone could be a liar
and i was like that is such a strong
play to use it's either
absolute truth or it's absolutely a lie
because he threw out the muslim card i
don't want to be controversial so
therefore
he's trying to play it up and then
they're yeah you said nothing
controversial so far
he is what you're saying bro are you
just gay no but we can't
you can just tell me are you guys okay
okay jonathan are you gay no i'm not hey
hey
we're homies this is i'll tell you what
this is the only episode of all of them
i've seen
i think that i remember that they've
literally just keep
asking straight out are you this are you
the mole
get dude just be honest like it's like
we're just
chilling here bro
i'm just so disheartened right now nabil
nabil there you go that's the strategy
right yeah yeah there you go
to be honest i'm not surprised i made it
as far as i did in the game i feel like
i played that hand really strong and i
was just like you know what
i'm a muslim it can't be me raise your
hand
if you would like to continue the game
can we talk about this for a second
come on continue the game dude continue
the game no jared continue the game
he didn't want continue
i want the money because i'm competitive
but i think the moles out
yeah right play the game come on we lost
is this is called trust
this is where it happens we lost
oh my god look at him
it's so funny oh my god i'm so nervous
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
all right so who is it i am so confused
hey who's the mole wait
all right who do you think it is
honestly type a comment now
i think oh it's gotta be the guy that
just went out four cups dude
i was shocked i thought it was what what
blessed the entire time i'm happy that i
made it as far as i've made
it well done that got it right away and
there are some like
okay i know this is going to be high
inside i thought he looked gay but he
was too
like obviously gay looking that it was
like i don't know
there was never a point where i thought
evan was the all well there you go
you can't know if someone's gay or not
it's got nothing to do with your
appearance
i think we proved it here thanks to
jupiter well done and let me just say
again
whatever you preferences sexually ain't
nothing wrong with that
it's respect why don't they just ask
describe your ideal girl that's a good
point
yeah dude let's just all kiss each other
whoever likes it is okay
i feel like they were this close to
doing that not available
who kissed the dude almost all raised
their hands they're all gay let's go
let's go it's so gay that it's straight
it's the straightest thing ever
what a great episode that was so fun all
right thank you guys
remember to subscribe if you haven't
we're trying to hit 107 million subs
which means tambourine will grow check
out figurine and all that good stuff
available now
see you tomorrow hey ah children of
nine parts it's time to raise what was
once forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
hoopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big
tv pre-order promotion
i mean